hello everybody and welcome back to our
kevinsites so in a lot of real-world
problems we have a whole bunch of data
that we're looking at it could be images
or text or audio whatever it is but the
underlying factor the underlying process
of the data could be much simpler in a
much lower dimensional space than the
actual data that we're looking at so a
lot of techniques in machine learning
they try to compress the dimensionality
of your data into a smaller space one
very popular technique that's used a lot
in recent papers is called variational
autoencoders it is going to be a pretty
technical episode so I hope you're ready
to dive into the mechanics of
variational autoencoders my name is
Xander and welcome to archive insights
[Laughter]
[Music]
so before we dive into the mechanics of
variational autoencoders I first want to
introduce normal autoencoders so I'm
going to assume that you're already
familiar with the neural network
architectures that we have things like
back propagation and all of that
so what an autoencoder does is it takes
some kind of input data it could be an
image or a vector anything at all with a
very high dimensionality it's gonna run
it through this neural network and it's
gonna try and compress the data into a
smaller representation it does this with
two principal components the first
component is what we call the encoder
the encoder is simply a bunch of layers
they could be fully connected layers or
convolutional that are going to take the
input and they're going to compress it
down to a smaller representation which
has less dimensions than the input and
this is what we call the bottleneck and
then from the bottleneck is going to try
and reconstruct the input by using again
fully connected or convolutional layers
and then the last function of training
an auto encoder is simply looking at the
reconstructed version at the end of your
decoder network and then you're going to
simply compute the reconstruction loss
with respect to your input and by simply
comparing pixel to pixel differences in
the output we can create a loss function
and we can start training our network to
compress images and so obviously you
have simple encoders that use fully
connected layers but you can just as
well swap them out with convolution
if you're working with images or
something like audio for example and if
you look at what's going on here if you
train a deep convolutional net work to
do encoding and decoding of a whole
bunch of images you're actually creating
a whole new kind of compression
algorithm and Google is actually
thinking of using these types of
networks for reducing the amount of
bandwidth that you use on your phone so
if you download an image then the full
resolution image is first downscaled
then it's sent through you over the
wireless internet connection and then in
your phone there is actually a decoder
that reconstructs the full resolution
image from the compressed representation
and if you apply this to something like
m-miss for example then it's very
interesting to see what these hidden
representations are actually learning so
here you can see a bunch of images where
on the left side you can see the input
digits that are being fed through the
network and then on the right side all
of those are reconstructed images but
you can see what happens if we change
the size of the hidden representation so
if we use only a 2d hidden
representation that means that our
bottleneck you know in the middle of the
network is only two variables then we
get reconstructions that look pretty
okay but they are very fuzzy and the
fuzziness is because you force the
entire information of your image to go
through two single variables and then
when you reconstruct obviously you lose
some of that detail and that is why the
images look so fuzzy if you use more
dimensions in your latent representation
that you can get reconstructions that
are much clearer and much sharper but
you need more information in that
bottleneck and it's interesting to note
that the exact same technique is applied
to image segmentation as well so you
take an input image you run it through
your convolutional encoder it goes
through a bottleneck representation and
then it gets remapped to a full output
image but in this case instead of
reconstructing the original image you're
actually trying to target a segmented
version of your image and it's exactly
this type of network that is used in
self-driving cars to segment the
different parts of the public road into
specific objects that a car needs to
detect okay so that's the basic idea
behind auto-encoders but there are a few
very clever tricks that you can apply to
an auto encoder to have it do some
really fancy stuff so imagine that you
start with a normal m-miss digit it's a
clean image nothing's wrong with it but
then you add a whole lot of
to it and you're going to run that noisy
image through your encoder network you
get through the bottleneck
representation and then you try to
reconstruct the image but instead of
reconstructing the noisy image what
you're going to do is try and
reconstruct the original clean image and
if you train this network and a whole
bunch of these noisy and nice digits
you're going to try and force the
encoder step to actually get rid of the
noise and this is what we call a
denoising auto-encoder and so you can
see here that by using this approach you
can actually train a denoising
auto-encoder that is very good at
removing noise from input images and
denoising images isn't the only thing
that you can do with this type of
approach so in this case for example you
take an input and instead of adding
noise to it you simply crop a
rectangular area out of the image and
you throw it away you replace it with
white or black pixels you feed that
input image through the network and you
try to reconstruct the original full
image and this technique is what we call
neural impeding it's where you take a
small part of the image you throw it
away and then you ask the network to
reconstruct whatever was there in the
input image and with this approach you
can do simple things like removing
watermarks from images but you could
also remove a parked car for example if
you are filming on a movie set in a
natural setting okay so now that we have
the basic concept behind a normal auto
encoder
let's introduce variational autoencoders
so the idea behind variational
auto-encoders is that instead of mapping
any input to a fixed vector you want to
map your input onto a distribution and
so the only thing that's different in a
variational auto encoder is that your
normal bottleneck vector C is replaced
by two separate vectors one representing
the mean of your distribution and the
other one representing the standard
deviation of that distribution and so
whenever you need a vector to feed
through your decoder network the only
thing you have to do is take a sample
from the distribution and then feed it
to the decoder and so to train a
variational auto encoder the loss
function in this case actually consists
of two terms the first term represents
the reconstruction loss so this is
really the same as the auto encoder step
except that here there is an expectation
operator because we are sampling from a
distribution and then the second part of
the loss functions is what we call the
KL divergence I'm not going to go into
all of the details because there is a
lot of math involved there but basically
what you want to make sure
is that the distribution that you're
learning is not too far removed from a
normally distributed discussion so
you're going to try and force your
latent distribution to be relatively
close to a mean of zero and a standard
deviation of one and so finally before
we can start training our variational
autoencoder we have one final trick that
we have to use because if you look at
the computation graph of our network
right now we have a problem in the
middle of that mat work after the
bottleneck we have a sampling operation
there is a node there that takes a
sample from a distribution and then
feeds that sample through the decoder
but the problem is that you cannot run
back propagation you cannot push
gradients through a sampling node so
this is an issue and so in order to run
your gradients through the entire
network and train everything end-to-end
we're going to use what we call the
reaper ammeter ization trick and so the
trick goes as follows if you look at the
latent vector that you're sampling you
can actually look at that vector as the
sum of a fixed mu which is just the
parameter that you're learning plus some
kind of a Sigma which is also a
parameter that you're learning and then
multiplied with an epsilon and this
epsilon is where we're gonna put the Siq
a stick part so this epsilon is always
going to be standard caution it's always
gonna have zero mean and standard
deviation of one we're gonna sample from
that epsilon and then multiply it with
Sigma ad mu and we have our latent
vector and so the clever thing here is
that now our mu and our Sigma those are
the only things that we actually want to
train so there we have to be able to
compute gradients and run back
propagation but that epsilon well that
doesn't really matter because we don't
want to change that epsilon ever again
that epsilon is a fixed elastic node
okay it's still sarcastic but we don't
have to run back propagation through it
so it doesn't matter that it's sampling
operation and so this is the repair
matter is a tient trick where instead of
having a full stochastic node that is
blocking all of your gradients because
you can't do back propagation through it
you're going to split it up into a part
where you can do back prop and then
another part which is still stochastic
but which you don't want to train
because it's fixed pretty clever right
so let's take a quick look at some code
in tensor flow so here you can see the
encoder network which is training two
sets of parameters the means and the
standard deviations of our distribution
and then in the actual auto-encoder
we're going to do a sampling operation
from the distribution to actually get
our latent vector and then the you can
see where they compute the KL divergence
and then you're actually going to
compute your loss and back proc through
it alright and so before we go and look
at some visual results of what you can
do with variational autoencoders I want
to note one final thing there is a new
class of variational autoencoders which
has a lot of promising results
that's called disentangled variational
autoencoders and the basic idea behind
this disentanglement is that you want to
make sure that the different neurons in
your latent distribution but they are
uncorrelated that they all try and learn
something different about the input data
and so to implement this the only thing
you have to change is add one hyper
parameter through your loss function
that weighs how much this KL divergence
is present in the loss function and so
in the disentangled version the auto
encoder will only use a specific latent
variable if it really has a benefit and
if it doesn't benefit the compression
then it will simply stick to the normal
so in order to show the results of a
disentangled representation let's look
at a very simple data set the data set
consists of images that are generated
from for latent factors so you have the
x position the y position the size of
the objects and the rotation of the
object and by just picking a sample from
that distribution you have four values
you can just generate an image that is
generated from exactly that hidden
representation and then the idea is if
you train a disentangled variational
auto encoder what you would like to see
is that the auto encoder is able to
reconstruct and come up with that exact
mapping of those four latent variables
to encode the information in its inputs
and it turns out that if you use the
normal loss function of a variational
auto encoder it simply comes up with a
whole bunch of latent spaces but it's
not really finding exactly those latent
variables that we use to generate the
images but if you disentangle your
representations it gets much closer so
here on the left side you can see that
by increasing that beta factor in your
auto encoder you're actually forcing
your auto encoder to map the information
onto only a few of those latent
variables so instead of using all ten of
them
the autoencoder only uses five of the
latent variables to encode the
information and you can see that the
first one represents the Y position the
second is the x position then you have
the scale which is the third one and
then in fact there are two latent
representations that the auto encoder
used for representing the rotation of an
object but interestingly all the other
latent representations even though they
are there they are still fixed at the
harshin distribution and this is because
they weren't really necessary to encode
the information of our input and here
you can see really interesting results
where they applied variational
autoencoders at google deepmind's on
their deepmind lab environment so you
can see a 3d world where an agent can
sort of run around and what they did is
they they compress the input images that
the agent is seeing in two latent space
and then they reconstruct it but what
you can also do is you can start
changing the latent variables and then
see what happens to the reconstruction
and so it turns out that if you use a
disentangled variational auto encoder
then changing the latent variables
actually corresponds to some very
interpretive things so here you can see
that changing the first latent variable
actually changes the color of the floor
but nothing else and then there are
other latent variables that correspond
to turning to the left or turning to the
right and there are even some that
changed the rotation and the identity of
specific objects that the agent is
looking at and in contrast if you don't
use this disentanglement then whenever
you start changing a latent
representation everything starts
blurring up in the image and it's not
really clear what this latent vector was
trying to encode and so I think this
image sums everything up on the left
side you have a disentangled variational
auto encoder and you can see that if you
change the first I mention in your
latent space then the face is rotated
but nothing else changes if you do the
same thing in a normal variational or
encoder the face also rotates but you
can see that a lot of other stuff is
changing as well and then as a
comparison on the right side you can see
the results for a generative adversarial
Network and so the holy grail of
disentangle variational auto-encoders is
to have some kind of a network that can
extract very useful causal features from
a very high dimensional space and then
use those
for some tasks that it's trying to learn
and the hope is then that those learned
features will also generalize to the
mains outside of your training data and
so one of the common domains where
people are trying to apply variational
autoencoders is for example in
reinforcement learning because the whole
problem in reinforcement learning is
that you have very sparse rewards and it
takes a really long time to train
anything so by using this variational
autoencoder
as some sort of a feature extractor the
hope is that you can actually run your
agent on the representation on the
compressed representation instead of on
the full input space and so when using
this in practice there is actually a
very clear trade-off if you disentangle
the latent space too little then your
network is sort of overfitting because
you give it too much freedom it can just
learn how to reconstruct your input
training data but it won't generalize to
unseen data in new cases on the other
hand if you disentangle too much then
you actually lose a lot of the high
definition detail in your input and this
can actually hurt performance in a lot
of applications so personally I find
this a really interesting idea and I'm
very curious if this will lead to some
types of networks that can learn to
extract very useful low dimensional
information from very high dimensional
spaces because in the end we want to
train agents that are able to understand
the world by compressing a whole lot of
information and then learning useful
behavior on that latent space all right
congratulations if you made it to the
end of this video I hope you learned
something don't forget to subscribe and
I'd love to see you again in the next
episode of archived insights
[Music]